oh
oh [ __ ]
roger what are you doing
federal authorities have initiated a
multi-state manhunt for
william butcher if anyone spots william
butcher or any of his known associates
marvin mill
q campbell or this man please call
1-888-0 crime
[Applause]
world still needs superheroes
so let's get out there let's take these
[ __ ] down
we are famous now don't you worry
daddy's home
ain't you twitch lucky that i showed up
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new boys season 2
comic-con trailer video
and breakdown of season three that's
right they announced that they renewed
the show for season 3 already so i'll
explain what they've said about season 3
so far
there's going to be a bunch more
comic-con trailers this week from
everyone so be sure to subscribe to get
all those videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with the boys in future seasons
if you thought it was messed up during
season one you have no idea how crazy
it's gonna get during season two
season three is going to be even more
wtf than that
but the first big clip here just meant
to be a big wtf deep
versus the boys like the seven are
trying to take down the boys as you saw
during the trailer there
it's open season on butcher in the boys
and for whatever reason
the boys have some mission that they're
on that's near a body of water
so surprise the deep is actually useful
for once
that's the whole joke of the character i
mean he's meant to be this big aquaman
parody so post all your aquaman memes
they tried to butch up the character big
time during the aquaman movie with jason
momoa but within the world of the boys
the other members of the seven
treat the deep like he's a total joke
like homelander can't stand him
the only reason that homelander
tolerates the deep is because vod
american
forced him onto the team so that you
have to work with this person
because it's all about our merchandising
empire the reason why those particular
members are chosen to be members of the
seven why they're so powerful
is so that they can sell more
merchandise they've just done focus
testing and it's all this big marketing
campaign like oh
if we put you people together people
will buy more merch
but in this clip he's chasing them down
using this giant pack of sharks
and a giant whale so make all the jaws
and moby
dick jokes that you want then as the
deep gets all high on himself like he
looks super proud of himself look at how
i'm gonna take them down i'm so amazing
look at my aquatic powers
i love that crazy look that butcher gets
in his eye as he speeds up instead of
slowing down like what is the easiest
way through this problem
literally to go through the problem go
through the whale
then you see that moment of recognition
on the deep's face as he realizes what's
getting ready to happen it just starts
freaking out
there's some more footage of this scene
in the trailer too you see them climbing
out of the whale carcass just all
covered in it just meant to be the most
wtf moment you could possibly think of
the whole thing with the deep you have
to remember is that he can literally
talk to fish in aquatic mammals during
the series like you would have a
conversation with another person
they made a bunch of jokes about that
during season one and during the
comic-con panel they kept referencing
the dolphin from season one
the dolphins the deep tries to rescue
but then goes completely off the rails
okay if i just touch it when you shut up
so the deep is just one of those
characters that lends himself to those
kinds of jokes like you think he's
messed up but then it
only gets more and more messed up as it
goes along
as of the end of the season he's still
been banished to the middle of nowhere
because of what happened with starlight
like you see him in this towny bar
just wrecking everything because he's so
pissed off with the way his life has
turned out
i don't know exactly when he comes back
to the seven team during season two
most of the seven story line during
season two at least at the beginning is
all about the superheroes in the
military thing like there was that whole
other clip where they introduced
stormfront like hey i'm joining the team
now
they made a deal with the government but
they also have to sway public support
for supers in the military which is what
homelander is mostly focused on in the
first couple of episodes
like this is what these rally scenes are
all about and they're just using
stormfront's initiation
into the seven to do that like you see
homelander blowing up some protester
with heat vision but then you see
stormfront using her comic book powers
of flight and lightning to win them over
one of her non-super special abilities
during season 2
is supposed to be social influence and
that's one of the reasons why
she was picked to join the seven that
doesn't really happen in the comics so
they are changing some of the stormfront
comic book plot
he never joined the seven he was the
leader of a team called payback that was
sort of like another version of the
seven but meant to be an avengers parody
in the comics the character is kind of
like a parody of
thor at marvel and the avengers and
shazam in the justice league at dc
all the members of the seven have
fictional backstories that voc created
for them
so in the comics stormfront actually
came from world war
ii he was created in a lab during world
war ii to be this german superpower
but because of operation paperclip all
the german scientists that came to the
united states to continue
compound v experiments brought
stormfront with them
vaude american was created they created
a fictional backstory for stormfront
and said that he was an ancient viking
with superpowers but remember it's all
a lie all superheroes in the world of
the boys are created in a lab
so vikings norse mythology make all the
thor revengers jokes in the comments
but she or he depending on whether
you're talking about the comics of the
show doesn't have a hammer or anything
like that
the very non-superhero power though that
she's supposed to have
is social media influence so it just
sounds like they're gonna use her within
the seven to sway public support for
supers in the military
she does have some cool powered fight
scenes with kimiko during season two
she won't just be walking around acting
super sassy all the time
part of the reason i think for them
going for aya cash for stormfront and
making the character a woman
is to make her a bit of a better foil
for homelander who's kind of mystified
by women
he's got that crazy edible complex going
on in season one with still well
so it sounds like stormfront is just the
next evolution of that personal problem
of his like how is he going to deal with
this other person
she's not as powerful as he is not
physically at least but i think they
just want to change the dynamic within
the seven because now he's kind of
realized he can do anything he wants
but there are other people who are super
powerful within the world of the boys
stormfront is just one of those other
people the way they talk about the
dynamic between stormfront and
homelander at the beginning though
as you saw in the clip that they
released a while ago is that he can't
stand her at the beginning like okay
i'll tolerate you because they say that
you're forced onto the team and i can't
do anything about that yet
but they did say that she would win him
over by the end of the season
and i think they're just playing for
that dynamic like if we start talking
about season three
the whole thing was season three like
i've been making a bunch of hero gasm
jokes like hero gasm would be the really
awesome thing for them to do during
season 3 if they want to get even more
crazy with the series
but they already kind of teased what the
plot of season 3 is
at the beginning of season 2. so in that
opening scene when giancarlo esposito
is talking about putting supers in the
military and who they're going to report
to
he also makes the comment that he
definitely does have the goal
of ordering people around in the white
house putting superheroes in the
government
actually affecting public policy that's
vots real end game
like they mostly exist to make more
money that's their whole goal but
really in order to do that on a large
scale to really get power they have to
be able to take over the government
they didn't say when they intend on
releasing season three but i think the
idea in renewing it so early is so they
can start filming later this year and
they can get season three out around
this time or later next year so that
it's on a yearly schedule relatively
reliable
just a reminder about the way that
they're dropping episodes this year so
the first couple of episodes will drop
september 4th then the rest of the
episodes will drop
weekly there'll be eight episodes total
just like season one but they also did a
bonus
movie for the boys it'll be a short
movie based on what's going on with
butcher's character and that'll air
after the finale
and what's going to be happening too is
we'll probably start getting some falcon
and winter soldier marvel episodes
around the boys finale too they haven't
confirmed the release date for that yet
but by the time we're talking about boys
episodes we'll probably know more about
when the marvel disney plush shows will
start too
it'll be fun going from the marvel dc
parody to the actual marvel episodes
speaking of justice league 2 there's
going to be a big justice league snyder
cut trailer that'll drop tomorrow of
course i'll do a video for that so as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see that video when i
post it
i just posted the entire opening scene
from marvel's new mutants movie so you
can click here to watch that
and you can click here for my last big
boys season 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight